يذهب إلى بوسان بكوريا الجنوبية حيث تعرض
زعيم حزب المعارضة الرئيسي
للطعن في رقبته بسكين في
الساعات القليلة الماضية فقط. لي جيانغ في
المستشفى في حالة واعية وقيل لنا
تحذير أننا على وشك عرض الصور
الهجوم الذي سيجده العديد من المشاهدين
مزعجًا على
الهواء مباشرة الآن لمارك ستيوارت من CNN في Soul
الذي يغطي هذا لنا، فماذا
نعرف ماذا حدث وما هي
الظروف أه ماذا سيحدث
بعد ذلك مرحبًا هناك جون اه، لقد كنا
نتابع هذا من أجل  الساعات الأربع الماضية،
سندخل في التفاصيل بعد
قليل، لكنني أعتقد أنه من المهم جدًا
تحديد مدى توتر وانقسام
الجو السياسي هنا في
كوريا الجنوبية. لي هو ليبرالي خسره في
الانتخابات الأخيرة للرئيس الحالي
يون.  بهامش صغير جدًا لكنه
يظل بارزًا جدًا على
المشهد السياسي أه هنا في كوريا الجنوبية ولم
يكن الأمر غير عادي بالنسبة له
أن يكون في الحملة الانتخابية لدينا
انتخابات عامة قادمة هنا في أبريل
حتى الآن  ماذا حدث كان في
موقع بناء عندما كما رأيت في
هذا الفيديو جاء رجل من الحشد
وهاجمه بسكين في رقبته أه
في هذه المرحلة تم
وصف حالته بأنها واعية كان أه في
مستشفى مصاب  سو في الجزء الجنوبي
من كوريا، وهو الآن هنا في سول وهو
بالطبع مركز متروبوليتان الكبير
وفقًا للمتحدث الرسمي. يعاني لي من
جرح صغير يبلغ طوله 1 سم في رقبته. وفي
وقت ما، رأينا صورة له على
الأرض  اه عيناه مغمضتان وكان هناك من
يستخدم منديل اه للضغط
على اه رقبته